here's morgan uncensored we'll celebrate
free speech with a lively debate an
agenda setting interviews appears you
described yourself in a very colorful
way
how did you describe yourself well it's
going to be airing in the u.s every
night in the uk every night in australia
every night so i'm now officially what
i've always wanted to be a global
irritant
and i want to irritate all the right
people all the people that we all find
uniquely irritating and it's this
permanently offended
snowflakey cancel culture mob who
descend like a pack of hornets on
anything they can get themselves into
trying to suppress everyone's right to
an opinion trying to tell us all how to
think how to act how to how to laugh
what to find funny what statues to
revere what parts of history are
acceptable what parts aren't and so on
and i think we're all just sick and
tired of it now whether you're in in new
york whether you're in london whether
you're in sydney everyone is fed up with
this we're fed up with this small vocal
permanently angry humorless
horrible group of people this woke
brigade and by woke i don't mean the
original interpretation of it which
meant just to be more socially aware of
social racial injustice i mean this new
creation of the woke canceled culture
which is somebody who believes their
opinion is not just the only one that
can be tolerated but that anyone that
deviates one iota from that opinion has
to be destroyed shamed abused and then
cancelled have their job taken away from
have their livelihood wrecked simply for
having a different opinion so i i think
the world's become a small place i think
that in terms of debate we're all having
these same arguments around the world
now and i think the vast majority of
people whether it's in america the uk
australia or other countries the vast
majority agree with me and i suspect
with the panel here that this pendulum
has gone way too far and that free
speech has got to mean what free speech
means and that doesn't just mean that
you tolerate opinions you agree with it
actually means the opposite as churchill
said it means it means listening to
people whose opinions you vehemently
disagree with but you tolerate a new
respect are you going to allow him to
drop churchill quotes on an american
television show greg gusted by it i'd
get up and slap him
if you do i'm going to walk off
when when you invite me to be on your
show i assume i'll be flown first class
and stayed at uh one of the finals
you'll actually be down the line from
your studio just to save money but thank
you but i'll take that as a yes you're
all invited obviously because i think
you will share probably share my view
about this which is i think we all feel
the same way right it's interesting are
you gonna do like one interview per show
it's gonna be people no i want to debate
look i want to take it'll be my take on
the day's news very much like like this
show right but i just want to have i
want to have people from all sides of
the political divide i want to get back
to what it used to be like where you
could have a tear-up argument with a
good friend about some issue in the news
and after was going to have a beer
together like meghan markle yeah
exactly there are some
exceptions council council
and i can only thank the american people
for taking ms markle back
we couldn't be more grateful
thank you piers we'll be watching on fox
nation thank you very much